you can tell we are getting very close
to an election because a lot of the
audience questions coming in relate to
the either the Democratic primary or the
eventual general election in November of
2020 so let's dig right into it first
question hey David is the establishment
strategy to split the Democratic primary
vote as much as possible to force a
brokered convention and let
super-delegates decide on the second
ballot so let's we first have to explain
this entire thing so you might remember
back in 2016 as the primaries were going
on you would see these estimates of how
many delegates each candidate had and
very often you would see for example
Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders with
like the same number or a close to the
same number of Delegates on the basis of
polling and thus expected voting in the
primary states but then you would see
another column which says plus
super-delegates and Hillary had like all
the super-delegates and then it would
seem as though Bernie simply had no
chance whatsoever of securing the
nomination even if you ran the table in
the primaries from that point forward
and this is one of the ways in which
people accurately said the DNC was set
up to deny Bernie the nomination in 2016
in to help Hillary Clinton which is that
even before any ballots were cast in
primaries by voters super-delegates were
already known and expected to be
supporting mostly Hillary Clinton over
Bernie Sanders so one of the things that
the DNC did since the last primary in
order to at least appear as though they
are trying to make the primary more
democratic as they said super-delegates
will not vote on the first ballot at the
convention so before the way it worked
is you would have all the primaries
leading up to the Democratic National
Convention the primaries would lead to
delegates being sent to the DNC the
super-delegates would be there and they
would say let's now vote and the
delegates would vote based on how their
state primary went and then the
super-delegates would vote you add them
all up and then somebody's the nominee
maybe or not you go to a second round
what the DNC decided to do is they said
in 2020 super-delegates will not vote on
the first round
therefore if a candidate has enough
support in the first round of voting
based solely on the delegates from the
primaries the super-delegates won't even
get involved but if after the first
round of voting there is not a nominee
on the basis of the rules then we do a
second round and the super-delegates are
then allowed to participate so if one
strategy was we need to appear as though
we are putting our thumb on the scales
less than in 2016 but we still want the
opportunity to do that you would say all
right let's get rid of super delegate
voting in round one push super delegate
voting to round two but let's try to
make it so that we get to that second
round make it so that there is not a
candidate selected in round one of
voting at the DNC and one way to do that
is indeed to split the vote but it's
actually a two-tiered strategy the
strategy you're talking about of
splitting the vote in order to get
super-delegates in a position to decide
on the second ballot there's a prior
strategy to that which is let's just
reinforce the establishment so that Joe
Biden or increasingly Pete Budaj win and
I actually was on TV last week talking
about this on the rising on rising the
hill the hills rising the show with
crystal ball and cigar and jetty and I
explained that even if it's not a
carefully crafted strategy if the DNC is
worried about Biden because they see
that he looks slow during the bait
during the debates they see that he's
not making a lot of sense on some issues
that every debate he drops in polling
the debate being more publicly visible
is worse for Biden if they're worried
about that they can say who's a good
alternative it's not Bernie it's not
Warren it's Buddha judge Buddha judges
the other establishment candidate that
we could get behind by supporting Pete
Buddha judge by giving him more airtime
speaking time during the MSNBC debate
for example they are pulling more people
into the universe of centrism and if in
the end those voters say you know what I
don't actually want to vote for Buddha
judge because he's not experienced
enough it's a very natural transition to
instead go and vote
for Joe Biden and so the initial
strategy is to basically default this
thing to Joe Biden but with the
understanding that Biden's having some
problems start supporting Budaj edge
just to get more people thinking
centrist rather than leftist like Warren
or Bernie and hopefully they will just
straight out win the nomination in the
first ballot on the basis of primary
results of course if it doesn't happen
the strategy of splitting the vote is an
effective one to try to eventually let
super-delegates decide on round two in
the Democratic National Convention so
they're doing it all it's a different
strategy than in 2016 because the rules
have changed but certainly don't be
confused for a second the establishment
knows who they want and knows who they
don't want and there are multiple
strategies happening at the same time to
try to make that a reality